[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد تواجه شركه نور
لينك للاجهزه الطبيه التي يملكها ملياردير
الامريكيه للمعسكر تواجهه تحقيق اتحاديه
الامريكيه في مزاعم بنتهاكات المحتمله
لحقوق الحيوان التحقيقات تاتي وسط شكاوى
من موظفنا بشركه من تسريع التجارب على
الحيوانات مما تسبب في نفق الكثير منها
وفقا لوثائقي طلعت عليها رويترز ومصادر
مطلعه كذلك على التحقيق وعمليات الشركه
الهون ماسك كان قد تحدث قبل ايام عن انه
من المتوقع بدء تجارب على البشر باستخدام
اداه اللاسلكيه تطورها شركته
المتخصصه في صنعاء شرائح المخ في غضون سته
اشهر لتعزيز القدرات البشريه مضيفا ان احد
اوائل التطبيقات المستهدفه هو استعادته
مصر وتقوم مشاركه بتطوير وصلات شريحه المخ
تقول ان قد تمنح المرضى المصابين باعاقات
القدره على الحركه والتواصل من الرديده
سنفهم هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من عمان
الدكتور رضراره البلعاوي استاذ ومستشار
العلاج دواء السريه اهلا بكم من الكويت
مستشار امن المعلومات والتحول والرقمي
رولاند ابو نجم اهلا بكم الكريم ماهي اسم
حالي ان نبدا من وجهه النظر الطبيه معك
دكتور ضرار هذا الحديث الذي يطرحه مع هذه
الفكره التي طرحها معك ويبدو بانه هيئه
الدواء والاغذيه الامريكيه وافقت عليها
مبدئيا بما انه قال انه سيبدا بعد سته
اشهر في توفير التاشيرات فهل هذا الموضوع
سيتم فعلا قادر ان يتم
تحياتي يا سيدتي لك ولضيفك والمشاهدين
الكرام الجواب نعم يمكن تحقيقه ولكن
التصريح المقتضب لاله الماسك عادته يكون
يعني غير مفصله وغير مفصل وبالتالي لا
نستطيع التعليق عليه لكن هل هذا شيء جديد
لا ليس شيئا جديدا يعني في تجارب كثيره من
شركات كثيره على همم يعني استعاده البصر
لكثير من الكفيفين ببساطه يعني التقنيه
اللي احنا اللي هي التلاحم بين الاله وبين
ال- ال- الدماغ ابراهيم كمبيوتر انترفيس
في هناك تجارب على استعاده ال ال ايضا
السمع وما هي زراعه القوقعه اللي احنا كنا
بالثمانينات نعتقد انها غير يعني حقيقيه
عباره عن يعني سماعه تجذب الاصوات وتحولها
الى اشارات الى العصب السمعي وبالتالي
بصير في عنا سمعه فما يقوله الى المصحف
حقيقي ليس جديدا ولكن ليس مفاجاه حتى هو
ان نعلق عليه هو قال بانه هذه الشرائح
كذلك او هذه الرقيقات ستمكن من خلق ذكاء
اصطناعي او من ان يتعامل البشر بطريقه
ذكاء الاصطناعي وشفنا الفيديو فيديو القرد
الذي تمكن من تحويل بعض الارقام دون ان
يمس الشاشه
فخلينا نسال من جانب التقني كذلك همم سيد
رولاند همم ما الذي يريده ماسك باختصار
يعني ما هدف ماسك من طرح مثل هكذا فكره
اول شيء مساء الخير عليك
الكريم
بموضوع انه هذا الموضوع انه جديد كمان انه
هذا الموضوع لهم ماسك اعمل له اخذ هذا
الاكسجين او اذا بدك هذه الاعلاميه كثير
كبيره وكل من هيك نحن هلا عم نحكي عنه انا
براعم
من تويتر
همم انقل لك على الاقل ما قراته في تغريده
ماسك وفي تعليقات بعض
المحيطين به ماسك لا يتحدث فقط عن عوده
البصر وعوده السمع هو يتحدث عن خلق شريحه
ان كنتم تستمعون للهتفات ففريقنا يتابع
فريقنا يتابع المغرب لا نعلم كم هي نتيجه
الان ولكن همم يبدو باننا تاهل ومبروك الف
الف مبروك اذا كما نتابع اسفل الشاشه
المغرب اياك غلب على اسبانيا بضربات
الترجيح وتاهل للدور الربع النهائي في
الماضي همم الف الف مبروك الحلقه ستعاد
ولكن اكيد بان لكل سيفهم بانه في همم همم
المباشر كنا نتابع هذا الموضوع المغرب او
المنتخب عربي يتاهل للدور الربع النهائي
في كاس العالم 1000 مبروك نعود لماسك
استاذ
رولاند يتحدث عن شريحه هذه الشريحه سبقه
واستعملت ووضعت في دماغ الانسان
قريبه من هذا الموضوع في الشريحه هنحطت
بمحل معين على دماغ من فوق وكان اذا بدي
كويس عم تنقل الطعم المعلومات هلا لاول
مره التجربه عم تيجي وحتى هو قال لي ست
اشهر هلا عم بده ست شهور تاريخ تراخيص من
امريكا وهيك طيب يقدر يحط هذه الشريحه
داخل الادماغ وحتى بتم تشريج هذه الشريحه
بشكل وايرلس مثل ما احنا نقدر نعمل
بطاريه تليفونها بشكل وايرلس هذا التحدي
يمكن اكبر تحدي انه عن طريقه الشريحه بشكل
مباشر مع الدماغ او من داخل الدماغ هذا
يمكن اكبر تحدي هلا عم يحكي عنه الدكتور
بيقدر يشرح اكثر مخاطر هذا الموضوع بس انا
برايي هذا الشيء مثل ما سببه لنا عم باخذ
ويقدر يوصلها للقضايا اللي فقدت التواصل
بين الدماغ بين الاعضاء
قادر دكتور ضرار
ستي اول شيء مبروك للمغرب مبروك ان جميعا
الجواب على سؤالك نعم يمكن تحقيقه يا
سيدتي احنا كما قلت انا في تعليق الاول
انه هذا ليس جديدا احنا في عندنا مثلا هو
ممكن تحدث عن علاج الامراض النفسيه
والعصبيه وهذا موجود احنا في عندنا بعض
الاجهزه نقوم يعني غرسها في الدماغ
لمعالجه الرعاش اللي هو الباركنسون ممكن
ايضا انه تستخدم هذه التقنيه زرعها ايضا
في الدماغ حتى انه حاول تجميع هذه الموجات
الدماغيه وتحويلها الى اشارات الى العضلات
حتى يستطيع الانسان ان يحرك بعض العضلات
ايضا نستخدمها في علاج بعض انواع الامراض
النفسيه مثل الاكتئاب في عندنا الان جهاز
اسمه ترانسلينج سيميوليشن هو احنا بنعمل
تفعيل او يعني
للدماء حتى انه يزيد من ال- ال- يعني
السيالات العصبيه السيليكون حتى انه
الانسان يتحسن مزاجه في الاكتئاب في عندنا
عشان في ان اس هذه كلها موجوده يا سيدتي
ما يتحدث عنه الى الماسك انا لا اجده
مستحيلا او جديدا ولكن انا اقول بانه احنا
تعودنا عليه يعني بال 2001 انا اذكر انه
تحدث مثلا عن همم انه احنا بدنا نعمر ال
ال كوكب المريخ بارسال نباتات من الارض
هذا قبل 20 سنه بال 2001 اين هو هذا الشيء
الحقيقه انه ابن الماسك دائما ما يخرج
يعني تصريحات لجذب الانتباه لانه يعلم
بانه همم يعني جذب انتباه الجمهور هو نصف
الصفقه ولكن ما تحدث عن علميا ليس جديدا
وعلميا يمكن ان يحدث ولكن برده انا بدي
اشيل طبيا بانه يتحدث عنه ايضا صعب صعب
الى درجه كبيره يحتاج الى وقت يعني لا نظن
لان هذا يحدث خلال الخمسه او 10 او حتى 20
سنه العلم ال- ال- الدماغ يا ستي
والاعصاب هذا شيء احنا لا نعلم عنه غير
اشياء بسيطه ليست بسهوله سيارات ليست
بسهوله تسلى ولا بسهوله يعني الفضاء اللي
كانت تحدث عنه او الصواريخ او ال ال ال
الهواتف المحموله لما نتحدث عن نيورولوجي
علم الاعصاب وعلم ال- يعني الطب النفسي
هذا الشيء بده وقت ولا نستطيع
يعني عقليه ايلين ماسك بزنس مان كرجل
اعمال بدي كل شيء بسرعه بدي كل شيء ويضغط
على الموظفين وهذه التقارير اثبتت بانه
موظفينه عم بتركه بسبب الضغط الجدول
الزمني اللي بده اياه هذا لا يمكن ان يحدث
في عالم الطب وفي عالم الدواء وانا بدي
احكي مثال الى زبث هو المشكله انكم
بتعرفوا القصه بتاعتها اللي حدثت في وادي
السيليكون في السيليكون غالي واخذ التسعه
مليار دولار واين هذه اللي حكت عنه بدي
اعمل يعني نقطه دم بدي اكشف كل يعني
الامراض فهذا ما اخشى الحقيقه اما كان
نظريا هو شيء جميل لكن هو نحن نعرفه وهو
موجود يمكن هو بده يحذف يعني برده انا
باتحدث
لا هو اللي بيسويه انه بتطلع حواليه باخذ
شيء ويحسن عرفت كيف هذا اللي بيعمله انه
الماسك زي ما حكيت يعني اتحدث عنه دكتور
ولكن هذا في احد انجاز طبعا
القدره العقليه والماليه حتى همم
يحسنوا في الامور الموجوده يعني لانه
تحسين الامور كذلك لما كنا من خلق من جلال
من التقدم على مستويات عديده ولكن ساعود
السيد رولاندو منذ قليل تحدث عن هدف ماسك
الاقتصادي والماليه همم هل تعتقد بانه هذا
الهدف الوحيد لماسك او انه يريد كذلك ان
يكون الى جانب شركته تسلا يريد كذلك ان
يضع شركته الطبيه همم امام الجميع امام
انظار الجميع ان يروج لها
لا لا اكيد بطبيعه الحال مثل السبع
والذكرات قال لهم مسيطر بمحل معين على
عالم السيارات مسيطر على عالم الفضاء
والانترنت على سبيس اكس وعبر شركه
الانترنت وهلا كمان عم يفجر ان انا كمان
ادي السيكل بموضوع بعالم الطب فهذا
الموضوع كثير اساس انه عم يقدر يفرش
سيطرته على عده قطاعات بنفس الوقت
او احد عند القدره الماليه عند القدره
التسويقيه عند اذى انه انا حتى يعني لما
شفناها باستماع رئيس الفرنسي ما كان بس عم
بيتناقش في الموضوع تويتر كان بيتناقش
بالموضوع
الطاقه البديله الغيره من التفاصيل اللي
هو رجل الاعمال
دكتور زهره
تفسير همم
تفسير علمي طبعا هناك فيديو كنت تحدثت عنه
منذ قليل روج له اصدقاء ومحيط ماسك على
همم وسائل التواصل اجتماعي قرد جالس امام
مكتب هناك كمبيوتر مفتوح القرد لا يلمس
الكمبيوتر ولكن لما يقال له يجب ان تحرك
رقم واحد او رقم اثنين هو بطريقه يعني مش
عارفه كيف يحرك هذه الارقام فقيل بانه هذه
الشريحه تمكن من تحريك المحيط او من
التحكم في المحيط دون حركه ما هذا
نعم 60 نعم هذا يعني انا برجع بحكي هذا
ليس جديدا هناك يعني دراسه
بال 2014 عملت ما يسمى بالتخاطر الفكري
يعني كان في همم يعني شخصين همم بعيدين عن
بعض كيلو مترات وصافي تخاطر بينهم عن طريق
انه الكمبيوتر استطاع ان يترجم الاطياف
الدماغيه من شخص وان يترجمها ويعالجها الى
الى اشارات تستطيع ان تعطي امرا للشخص
الثاني انه يضغط على نفس الشيء بالنسبه
للتجربه
الحيوانات نستطيع ان ناخذ الاردن
شكرا
سريري ومن الكويت ومستشاره امن المعلومات
والتحاول الرقمي رونالدو ابو نجم شكرا
جزيلا لكما همم
ناتي الى نهايه بانوراما لهذا المساء من
جديد الف الف الف مبروك لفريق العربي
الوحيد المنتخب العربي الوح تتمكن من
التاهل همم نلتقي غدا في نفس التوقيت
السلام عليكم